[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
you
20 strong chess players from nine
Federation's compete in st. Louis us
chefs champs calm presents the third
annual winter chest classic hello and
welcome back to our live coverage of the
2019 winter chess classic as always
baring our hosts my name is Caleb Denby
back in my in my seat here taking it
back from Ben Simon joined by the lovely
Sabina foyer so Sabina I wasn't here
yesterday so maybe for my benefit and
the viewers at home anything exciting
happen while I was gone a lot of
exciting things happen yesterday I think
it was great having been here as well
but you know it's always nice to have to
switch sometimes I'm so glad I don't get
switched at the moment you're
irreplaceable nobody to replace you but
there's some interesting events
yesterday and um I think as the
tournament advances we might see more
draws but also maybe the players could
get tired and we might see blunder so
it's really exciting yeah it's the the
middle of these tournaments where things
really kind of shake out right you get
the leaders who near the end really have
to start racing for points and then you
get the the trailers who kind of just
start you know trying to you know take
points away yes that's really yeah they
might they might start slow with some
draws and maybe a loss but then you know
it's quite a long tournament nine rounds
not that long I still have personally I
would be looking for players like
Geoffrey Zhang and Alexei Serena and
Gregorio proned those top seeds to
really find their form and start running
away but separating themselves from the
pack a little bit that's true and in the
a group also maybe var Akopian yesterday
he had a very beautiful wing yeah I
guess he's been struggling a bit in the
first couple he did he didn't he was
very disappointed for his second round
loss because he had a much better
position and then yes
he came joined us and we went through
his he's beautiful wind so a lot of
players you know can do can do creating
these events and absolutely well why
don't we see where we actually stand in
the a group with our a standings
Jeffrey zhang drew his round three game
bringing him to two out of three also
tied with him at two out of three is
Grigori oprand
daniel NORAD its key marina Jumma by of
and sam Semyon also joins the leader
leaders after a nice win yesterday
who've honest caboose ian and victor
Erdos still very much near the top of
the pack with one and a half out of
three and trailing is Alexis Rona vara
Cobian and sethu and why don't we see
what's going on in the B group as well
there is one leader in the B group and
that man is the only FM in the
tournament although the title is a bit
deceiving of course is a very very
strong player very much deserves to be
in the mix with these these grandmasters
and he is actually leading with two and
a half out of three trying to catch him
is Malik watching Tigran her route Union
Federico Perez poncy and Sergei azeroth
all with two out of three
Justin Wang is having a pretty
reasonable tournament as one of the the
lowest rated and especially one of the
youngest one and a half out of three is
not bad at all
yeah and he defended position so I
thought he probably won't be able to
hold it but he'd even defended really
well and saved a draw yesterday so he's
staying at 50% for the moment and we're
seeing tenacious play from Jess for sure
yeah Emilio Emilio Cordova and
Christopher you and L Sean rowdy body
Christopher of course one of the younger
players as well one of those top you 14
players along the justin line so those
players are all on one out of three and
Christopher you despite two losses
actually had a very nice win against
Emilio Cordova and round two so be on
the lookout for for Christopher you did
take some more full points away from
these shores and lastly we have Sergei
Aaron Berger
the B group here we see the tournament
hall with all the players hard at work
but why don't we take a look at the
format of this tournament
we of course have 210 player round
robins that would be the a group and the
B group that we just took a look at the
time control for the event is 90 minutes
for the first 40 moves at which point 30
minutes is tacked on for the remainder
of the game
and there's of course a 30-second
increment from move one of the game
there's also a draw rule in effect there
are no draw offers permitted before
blacks thirtieth move of course the game
could still be drawn by repetition mm-hm
but until black makes the 30th move the
players cannot agree to a draw which
makes this event more exciting for us as
commentators and people watching ensure
its decisive games at least a good
fighting draws rather than you know the
players getting to the board and leaving
quite quickly it prevents that someone
why don't we take a look at the schedule
for this tournament somehow it's a
brutal schedule after nine rounds with
no rest days in between thankfully just
the one game per day each round starts
at 1 p.m.
except for that final day when they
start a couple hours early to make room
for playoffs our show will be going live
at 3:30 p.m. each day two and a half
hours after the start of the round and
on that last day we will also be moving
our show earlier to keep in time with
the round well we'd like to thank all of
you guys out there on the internet for
joining us on YouTube be sure to get
involved on twitter using the hashtag
winter chess classic and if you'd like
to follow the games for yourself you can
do so at us chess champs calm click on
any game you want to see what the engine
has to say don't just take it from us do
some analysis yourself but other than
that if you have any questions in the
YouTube chat we'd love to read those out
especially if you guys have any
questions for the players when we get
them in for an interview we could always
use some more interesting questions to
ask them
well that's the that'd be great for sure
I feel like I'm just sort of positive
every time I seen them to walk us
through the game I changed it a little
bit so hopefully all right I can become
more creative absolutely I think that's
enough housekeeping why don't we take a
look at some games and see the pairings
in the a group sethu is playing against
Victor Erdos that's a very interesting
game that hopefully we'll get to take a
look at soon Farah Kobe is against we're
not in Juma buy of the gore Oberyn has
already drawn his game against the Lexus
Toronto it's temporarily puts grigory at
the top of the leaderboard with two and
a half out of four Geoffrey Zhang is
playing Daniel nerd it's key in an hour
he matchup of the day we have Sam 7
squaring off against Havana's kibou zine
Sam 7 one of the leaders coming into
today is looking to score a full point
against Havana's and move into clear
first for sure and we see him right now
focusing he they're about they reach
move 27 and I believe he's really lone
the clock so that might be a tough tough
next moves for Sam I think it's not so
it's not such an easy position to play
but the position is kind of close so
that's a good thing about it that if you
don't have too many tensions and don't
need to calculate specific direct moves
it can help you make the moves a little
bit faster but still I'm not so happy
about the time what do you think yeah
the time deficit definitely going to be
a huge factor here I think this is a
pretty complex position actually and so
having to play moves quickly you start
to just rely on the natural moves and if
your opponent is good which for Hanukkah
boozing is definitely a strong player
they can start playing moves that that
make the natural moves not so good they
really have to you have to play some
unnatural looking looking things
sometimes that's true dude that is true
yeah but but also like it's the person
who has more time is put in a difficult
situation because it's not so easy to
manage that extra time sometimes you
know you feel like okay I have all this
time I can take it I can think a lot and
try to make
the best possible move and my opponent
will be you know in a difficult
situation but then you might just waste
a lot of time yourself trying to find
the best move when in fact you could
just make natural myself the classic
chess adage think long think wrong
sometimes the time pressure can actually
be a you know I wouldn't say benefit but
it can be relieving right you know it's
like okay I have two minutes I'll play
the move that I think is best
that's true let's leave yourself room to
overthink things yeah enough about the
puck what's going on the actual board
here yeah so we got a very interesting
position for sure I mean we had a benoni
and I'm not I mean I like the fact that
white was able to to keep the the
bishops on the board but the position
and they got this c4 outpost I mean this
is a move the black usually doesn't rush
to make they usually once c4 much more
than they want to play b4 because you
know they give up this outpost but the
problem for white here is that because
of the way the pawns got traded so there
was a trade here in d5 and then white
also captured in f5 that's how we have
this pawn structure with white stayed
with this somewhat of a buuck pawn in d5
it would actually be great if I could
get rid of it because we would have
ideas with Bishop d5 yes attack stuff
like that yeah a lot of ideas was
sacrificing this pawn and then g6 can be
weak the lights where's our open
complain but with the pond there we
usually get these outposts and of course
once again I did mention the c-4 one the
problem is white only has one night and
right now it's on the other side of the
board so to get it to one of those
squares is not going to be so easy so
let me ask you a question sure elevating
positions so in positions like this I
feel like they can be kind of difficult
to evaluate right both sides have
weaknesses and both sides have a lot of
pieces on the board so something I've
tried to do is to look at the plants and
for here I don't really see the clearest
plan for white whereas for black I feel
like he simply wants to play a five and
a four and get his rook into the game
via the a file so if I had to pick I
think I would definitely prefer black
here but what are your thoughts do you
so that's an interesting idea just so
usually like I I I do a step-by-step
evaluation you don't always have the
time to do that like wicked King Safety
Space Center yeah the imbalances in the
position and see who seems to be doing
better and this is you know a little bit
unclear but that f5 point that I've
mentioned previously is a blacks
weakness right now that I think should
be something that white can think about
to try to put pressure on and then that
there's the e-file it's not immediate
that white can bring the rook on the
e-file because we have to deal with this
very annoying bishops III skewering if
you're gonna play rook e1 but I I would
think that this bishop in f3 is not
meant to stay there anymore
and I would like to improve it for black
you know I can play Bishop c3 and then
Knight g7 my weakness is defended and
then I don't see anything to stop me for
playing a five and a four usually we
would want to do something like this
okay um were through e to d3 no but I am
worried about the five a little bit I
have seen okay not so often but I have
seen sometimes white moving this night
away from g3 and trying g4 it's not
going to be an easy task to do but yeah
it's for sure not not so easy and but
even if you play like for example for a
black you think the plan could be a five
and for a four and they I do like that
idea but if you do move your ruca way on
the other side of the board then you
will you know leave the f5 column
protected so it's kind of tough I think
for both sides to come up with with a
good plan here if you're if you're not
really playing these types of positions
very much yes so easy to get distracted
definitely I used to study the benoni
for both colors and I I would play it
against my dad when I was a kid
and I would lose with both colors so I'm
not I'm not so sure what to say yeah
many things have been said about benoni
but no one can argue it's a very
fighting opening that's traits and
balances and it makes the game not very
interesting and very difficult so this
is certainly a game to look up for and
we like knowing that caboose ian has so
much time I think we can maybe go to
other games to come back see what's what
is happening what plans they come up
with well yeah why don't we check out
what's going on in the B group then we
have to be parents
mr. Aaron Berger is playing the
youngster Christopher you Sergey Azeroth
squares off against Al Sean Marathi
Abadi Tigran Haru Union plays emilio
cordova today Melek pocheon is facing
Justin Wang and then in our key matchup
of the day we have Federico Perez poncy
playing the group B leader Alexis orokin
Alexei of course with two and a half out
of three a very strong start to the
tournament and Federico trying to catch
them today so what do we have going on
in this game let's take a look we have a
little bit more balanced time situation
with both players leaving themselves
themselves enough room to work but
actually it's just move 20 and this guy
is true so for sure we're going to see
some very exciting time trouble moves
yeah I think whenever there's there's
more moves than minutes more moves to
make than minutes you have to get there
you're in for a scramble I think so it
looks like we had if we look back at the
opening
we had real apes' a six Bishop a4 aa
9797 line so now the typical
not the typical array Lopez actually
this is something that has happened in a
in another game yesterday here so 97
Bishop III and now white goes for d4
directly I have seen a lot of players
try to play first c3 prepare to play d4
so they make sure that in case of a
capture they would stay with a you know
two pawns in the center
um so this is this is something else
that there I can do but hear their
response I guess I wanted to just be a
little bit more aggressive just open
things up immediately yeah just open up
so now we seen night a fine it kind of
makes sense right yeah I mean III know
very little about this particular line
but it seems like black is spent to
Tempe to prove this knight to e7 and
then g6 so White's playing a little bit
more freely in the center that is true
but the difference would be that when
you have the 19 f6 e 5 is so easy and
white to play chasing a night away and
then you have a huge problem with
whether you're going to place the knight
Knight
so here in a way you know you're safer
with a knight but you do waste a lot of
time and so that's that's something that
you always have to get give something to
get something in return in chests
especially when you're playing black
pieces I think you can't get as much at
least not in the beginning
well black made some more knight hops
than that 85 yeah now he's getting the
light square bishop if he wants to he
didn't rush because now the bishop is
kind of closed and it's not like you can
move it because this pawn would be
hanging so white seems like you know
they follow some very natural
development paths
now the knight comes to e5 just putting
a little bit more pressure and having
the 1985 actually I like it because you
have ideas with 94 as soon as you push
the pawn so we're gonna have some
threats to chase this Bishop away
okay so Queen e2 defending the c4 pawn
d6 like I said threatening some 94 ideas
so I decided to play h3 and now we are
going to prepare potentially for some f4
breath
finishing development I've always found
these positions to be very very
difficult for the white player you have
to time f4 very very carefully that's a
very weakening move and well it does
even make a lot of threats
it also loosens you your Kings side
pretty heavily indeed yeah like it's
it's so tough and a lot of openings is
not just an e4 in D for openings also
sometimes you're playing maybe yes I'm
like orbit maybe but
and you want to play a four but then
you're thinking a lot about your efore
pawn or incident yeah yeah very very a
double-edged position despite you know
the closed kind of feel to it right now
mm-hmm
and it's kinda it was kind of
interesting here to see black going back
Knight to c6 not actually I wanted to
take the bishop in b3 what do you think
about this choice that Bishop isn't
isn't the greatest bishop I've ever seen
but maybe he was who's actually worried
about opening up that file for white I
mean do you think pawn takes and so he
would recapture I'm not so sure if you
can oh maybe we have this intermediate
or maybe that's why he didn't go for it
yeah and then you can take on then yeah
because now you have to recapture and
then we take yeah with a minute wait not
so sure about that can we take with the
Queen can read temporary sacrifice mmm
it looks quite complex actually so maybe
Pont X is in fact the move they move
directly not not rushing to taking these
things just wanting to take the next
move and then trading the bishops right
and then I guess I'm just gonna have my
ideas of playing b4 eventually but it's
a little tough to see how you're
actually achieve it that's why I was
thinking why I wasn't black taken b3
maybe there's some tactical idea that
we're missing but I just feel that the
knight could take you know it's it's
very interesting this opening I mean
both Italian and real apes' I think are
very interesting because you see this
bishop getting out and then it's he's
going to be chased away by this Knight
you know Knight a5 and then they go the
bishop goes to c2 and it stays stuck
because usually there are two points
here and then you're wondering what am I
going to do with this Bishop but
oftentimes you get to trade a bishop in
e5 and then push the pawn forward yes
any consolation suddenly looking at your
seven-inch you're feeling a little bit
better about life that's that's the
thing so it's never so clear like should
you take it soon should you let it there
anyways
I listen missing something I would
probably just go go for go for the
bishop but let's see how how white
continues here so yes it does force
black to make a decision with his knight
or white to make a decision
yeah and he also didn't want to take I
mean probably he was thinking hmm I'm
not so sure I want to open the F file
yeah you open the file and then I don't
think I definitely don't think II want
to take on c5 yeah it's very key d4
square and 94 would be devastating
for sure and the Knights are ready for
that if that comes and then the other
night can come to support it and then in
that case you really will die with that
Bishop answer saying even if you get it
- C - we will play v afterwards and the
bishop will be completely restricted so
yeah we saw Knight see - instance so
nice you - in case black would be the
one trading probably we would recapture
with the night well even pawn takes is
sometimes reasonable in these positions
right just to clamp down on this d4
square as well as the f4 square usually
yes but III wouldn't do it when that
file is open and you would have to
double pawns okay when you're still
having a long day three enough I felt
that that's a little bit too much but
Queen takes or Knight takes yeah either
one of those should be fine yeah because
we know like even ninety four is going
to be played we should we should not
care as much if we lose that Bishop
since what it says like didn't want to
take it in the first place yeah if you
didn't play Knight a5 63 while you would
you play 94 takes yeah waster Nestor
example in process alright so let's
let's catch up to the main position here
I mean the the current position of the
game so why is this finishing
development so finally they're going for
the 96 it's very interesting very
interesting approach but this bone
structure it's not as bad for black as
some might think because the pawns are
linked and sometimes you get to play c5
and you have a pretty nice chain of
ponds controlling a lot of the center
yeah you see the structure and
positions right obviously in the Scotch
sometimes black just plays d5
immediately mm-hmm that's e6 pawn can
kind of transfer itself onto the d5
square but this structure actually
controls a lot of central squares yeah
and I think hmm more from why it was
actually achieved this and I don't see
to it was actually quite a nice piece
yeah it's controls d4 so now and now
black stays with the night that's not
really on the right path yet to come
back to d4 which is the the outpost
where they would love to go eventually
they could get it there but it will take
a little bit of time so black finds
themselves in a situation they have to
train the bishops Queen takes okay very
very interesting maintaining the night
here to control that d4 square yeah
suddenly white might even be using that
square for his own pieces the black and
black went for c5 hoping hoping for this
trade so that they would get their
knight into play but of course you know
we are not going to undable black stones
we're going to play a three simply a tea
and I think some more moves that
probably yes and I mean let me refresh
my position here so a five was played
wow that's very committal because now of
course this allows the push from white
b5 and we really don't have a way to
challenge this pawn except by playing c6
which would really weakened our d6
control as well as even even the b6
square would become weak making this
point yeah I'm not quite sure if that
was right to be played by black I mean
you don't want to keep this night in d7
forever but this is like I guess the
nihms our style of doing things right
you trade off your dark square Bishop
and then you put all your pawns on dark
squares and then you attack the like
it's bad that is true but but in those
cases you attack the King yes
once he's attacking a c4 pawn right
imagine Knight b6 and this is Sarah all
right what white is getting or black is
getting some play oh it looks a little
artificial to me
I agree I
I mean I'm not sure what the maybe five
is a better square that than B six but
we had the thing here compared to those
phone structures I think is that the
those phone structures are usually it
right like that or maybe sometimes you
have opponents e5 you kind of place them
so I'm at ninety five rather than the
night peace okay stillness and just
trying to think black sometimes can have
have some chances to attack the kingside
whereas here and e5 pawn gives you that
f4 Square access rule and that's
sometimes really annoying to get the
knight coming to F for attacking g2 but
right now White has this efore pawn
technically a little bit more space
themselves on the kingside so we'll have
to we'll have to see how the game
continues but we have a few more moves
here so Queenie to protecting c4 alright
and now he's going Nagi sees okay so
he's still coming for the attacking
ideas trying to take advantage that
these Knights are of whites are not
really on the best possible yeah not
just yet notice wait I played this h3
move early on to try and you know hints
at playing f4 later and keeping control
of g4 but now it's kind of working
against him now his dark squares have
become a bit weak you can't really ever
play g3 to defend this of course yeah
because h3 of course is hanging in this
position and the light squares would
just be decimated so looking a little
testy for white I think tough to control
this at Foursquare
it might be tough so he probably wants
or should do something like rook f1
maybe bring this other look to e1
because those will be the places where
he might want to push the pump
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back and some brief technical
problems there but we're back in action
and there's actually a very interesting
development in one of the games that we
need to take a look at it as soon as
possible
yes for sure in the game of satu who was
actually not having the best tournament
but in this position he finds himself
with more Queens on the board always a
pleasure for a player to have more
Queens and how did this exactly happen
yes
[Music]
so we had a pretty normal opening here
right Bishop c5 it's one of the main
lines here is black c3 I could find the
center Bishop g5 h6 Bishop h4 typical
moves we've seen before
well right for someone who plays e45
this should be something you're studying
in the beginning and then we see this
interesting move rook e1 for white here
preparing actually I think if I've
probably just like if I'm just adding
more support to the pawn is oh yeah
white of course didn't really want to
develop the knight from b1 because he
want to recapture on c3 so he's kind of
like a gambit just giving up that pawn
ticket c3 I'll develop by night and I'm
going to take advantage of the fact that
your bishop is actually on the other
side of the board of course oftentimes
we develop that bishop in d7 I mean some
of the main lines if you want to play
the main real apes' lines yes but here
is d6 from black controls the e5 bother
with with this c3 pawn at all and then
white takes in c6 just messing up a
little bit there pawn structure black
takes in c3 intermediate center medve
Knight takes back which is what white
expected and and now in this position
with white you have a pawn down but you
have to try to find some ways to take
advantage of this pin so white is going
to bring their Queen a little bit more
active so setter is playing Queen to c1
maybe envisioning some pressures
over there somehow Queen afford I would
love to play I'm not sure if tactically
that move with the work we need to make
sure g5 is not possible I would not play
it I don't think it is I think it
actually looks reasonable right for g5
might just take it yeah just I mean you
have to to have the feeling and make
sure you're comfortable sacrificing the
PC I feel like it should work so blood
goes for a rookie eight and now maybe
you know thinking of some escape path
again you know or maybe having rookie
six to protect the knight in case of
some queen of four you know so keeping
an eye on that e5 pawn or eforp on
possibly five for sure sorry five so the
Rahman is just going directly for a very
aggressive move and this idea is often
seen in some other kinds of openings for
Indy for openings to like maybe a
Pannonia you will see this pawn
sacrifice and the idea is you actually
are freeing the square where the pawn
was right so you play e5 they have to
capture and then you're going to go to
Knight e4 so actually creating a square
for your knight at some point last year
I was teaching here at the club and one
of the classes was that's the secret
life of pawns
I really enjoyed actually prepared a few
games with this but night comes putting
the pressure and the Queen gets opened
as well so a lot of interesting ideas
there right also notably sometimes
you'll see a pawn sacrifice like this
because it actually the pawn gets in the
way for the opponent as well black just
brought this work to eat yet and now it
can't look at the e-file anymore that is
true this isn't the way getting the rook
blocked it's and now you know White has
two points down but it's not as simple
because now they're going to go for some
tactical ideas and I really like this
move Knight takes e5 of course it takes
e5 the idea is Knight takes up second
yes on takes f6
sixty-five and the pin maintains on that
pond now that pond is hanging this one
is hanging white should be having an
amazing position maybe close to winning
here but this is actually where black
crumbled okay I was we're shocked both
of us we were just about to go live and
we saw this move being played right
Knight takes e4 and we're like what what
are we not seeing here what is happening
so let's keep count of the pieces black
took one night yeah and now white takes
one clean so Bishop takes Yates and then
that's a piece for a queen but every
Bishop back to King age one
well they had two pawns previously and
race announced pieces and one was
captured on our two pawns a piece them
to fall for the Queen and after Bishop
e1 throw the moment Black has a rook and
a bishop and two pawns pretty clearly
the Queen which you would think okay
that's great III would love to play that
position yeah and you showed me earlier
so as we saw today black might have
expected Queen take c1 that the most
natural move and then rook takes e5 and
this boot should I actually don't think
it's so bad for black y can play Bishop
c7 maybe hitting the rook will just play
maybe rook e8 mm-hm and it'll just be
some kind of position where black is
it's maybe holding with with the two
rooks and the bishop for an exchange for
that Queen but actually what has a much
better move than Queen takes a loss yeah
and since her mom played it almost
without hesitation I think yeah pretty
immediately just queen f4 and now the
problem for black is the knight is
defended the bishop is hanging the
knight is hanging f7 is hanging
everything seems kind of collapsing yeah
black no way no way to solve all of
those problems yeah and so probably this
was also the moment that black spend a
lot of their time trying to understand
how how could they miss this this idea
what what you
Queen afore you know the problem
sometimes with with calculating long
lines is that you sometimes can forget
if they're not completely forcing right
you can sometimes forget moves like
Queen f4 and it's happened to all of us
and and now what to do I mean you have
to escape with the you have to choose
run the pieces with which you're going
to escape from the threat if you think
there's going to be no maid you can of
course sacrifice the f7 pawn which is
what exactly what black did just saving
their Bishop thinking okay if you're
going to take here maybe I can try to do
something like 56 maybe but it looks you
sure Bishop d6 Bishop d6 maybe I can I
wonder if I could take and c6 maybe or
maybe not well I mean yeah I know I
don't know I don't know what else and
maybe just let it mmm
it's tough I'm not sure what maybe he
can just think okay well we have this
pin made and then King h8 and then we
had a few more moves Knight to g6 check
the king went to h7 and now first night
of for chasing the rook away and trying
to define some mating this rook has very
very few squares
Ruki five and now squares is available
for the Queen you can imagine this this
York on a one trend get into the action
somehow maybe via the f1 Square and
things they're just falling apart
collapsing very for black seems to be
collapsing I mean here's the thing when
you get a winning position you have to
keep your calm you have to not think
okay I'm completely winning why's my
opponent still playing if you start
thinking that way you're completely
losing touch of of the position well
yeah the good news for white here
you don't have to kill the king yeah you
have a full queen for a rook you can
simply I don't know take c7 you can play
queen g6 and takes c6 just start
collecting all these pieces and there
won't be much that that I can really do
about it yeah I agree I feel like they
should be able to just start collecting
the pieces he might just make give a few
checks and kind of decide which ones to
collect because c6 of course is also an
option if Queen g6 checked and maybe we
can take that c6 phone instead of the c7
pawn you have to think if you're not too
worried about some I mean some kind of
ideas I'm trying to think for ideas for
black like so I'm not to give up we see
Queen g6 and King g8 or actually on the
board alright and so who does in fact
capture this e6 pawn all right did he
just do that yes he did alright so we
have this is the current position and
hmm very very interest and they believe
black made a move Knight of to check yes
I too have to check so now King g1 we
should see on the board I supposed to be
Bishop c5 is black side yeah but I I
don't know if you can really get away
with that Bishop c5 I think can you just
play Queen takes Turk
I'm thinking I don't know if there's any
kind of discovery the black could try oh
you know look at this beauty check okay
where do you go that's it looks like
Sunday's - it's me yeah I can be very
very exciting if wanna be terrible
disaster disaster disaster s
this would be a draw so we cannot
capture that rook we should be very
careful about it I mean let's make up
for it I wonder why he's thinking cuz
his next move is really forced King Ji
Won I mean did he play it or what is it
snow actually five was actually played
so what are we going to we have to solve
this problem let's solve it let's try to
solve it cuz mm-hmm imagine we were in
those situations what would we do
maybe you can play okay wow this is
actually more difficult than I was
expecting
maybe we can do rooks team one there's
still just it's double check right so
yeah well the idea was 94 over 94 was
trying to take h2 mate 93 I can go King
F honest no mate our checks or anything
you might I wonder if this would work
something with the bishop though but
there's no squares for this like square
tisha
unfortunately hmm oh but I wonder could
I play like just push up on like H h3
might might just give the King the h2
square yeah but no g4 still 94 94 king
h1 night up to now I go to it feels like
there should be some simple solution
this for white bike just doesn't have
enough pieces but there should be we're
not there so we can try giving up more
more pieces here
I guess King H - hmm you might take my
knight
but now I might I might take your rug
for real this time yeah I did you know
dissipate it's gonna take the rug I
should I do not anticipate too many
checks maybe like a few more luckily my
bishop controls g5 you're chasing me a
bit but yeah but III I'm in the center
of the board I think I'm free let's hope
I'm in yes definitely yeah it's it's not
nothing from black so you're gonna see
Seth you take some time here make sure
he figures it out
yeah but into the good this one should
be well in hand for him so where do you
wanna jump to next what looks the most
interest um shall we stay to the a group
or maybe we should go to the B group a
little bit let's check out the B group
because there's some some some
mismatches I think do you this game of
Melek cartoon versus Justin winged I
think white is actually pressing in this
end game we see the players there white
of course not up upon but with this
extra pawn for black being on c6
compared to e5 it starts to feel like
white does just have an extra pawn what
the knight should be better than the
bishop because the bishop is light
Square and it cannot attack all of these
you know all of our pawns locked on the
same color so the only person who can
try to play for a win here is white now
we need the first thing every time you
see a position where that's close
working opponent game I think you should
always ask yourself can I get into that
King important game yes now here what do
you think
could we get wait actually it's white
among so he cannot we're gonna check it
out but we should not be able to get
into the King important game yeah King
in fun and games should be winning for
whites because you'll give this e5 pawn
for this e6 pawn yeah and there's b5
Falls and then a for Falls and c4 fall
everything I mean you could try we it
has to be a little bit calculated to
make sure that by the time you go grab
all of those polls on the Queen side
that black mine
you know does not get the chance to you
know capture these balls go with the G
funds you have to calculate a little bit
but it should be winning for for white
if you go into a king opponent game but
now it's White's turn and so maybe maybe
95 keeps the e6 square under control but
then what's next for white I guess isn't
it I would think maybe 95 and then king
c5 and I do want to get rid of these
these nasty pawns on the Queen side 95 I
like it I don't see a way to stop the
entrance of this King it's it's also
corralling this Bishop a bit it's
difficult to put this Bishop on a square
or it can comfortably control c6
but yesterday Justin van has saved a
very difficult position in my opinion so
maybe yeah we actually see 95 on the
board I believe from catching okay and I
guess the key question is can black it
away with Bishop e6 I feel like it's the
only trying here that that keeps us so
you're doing active in case a trade
you're saying yeah I have I just so if
you play King you for I'll play C 5 and
then I'm threatening I'm not threatening
anything I guess but it's difficult for
you to go here yeah this is what we have
to calculate and see if it works or not
which pawn shall we take because black
well anyways promote the Jeep on he's
going to take this and then go with the
Jeep on yourself um so that yeah
probably this one the problem for black
is I don't think he can play say so King
d3 makes sense for white I think t3 or
d5 I'm still I don't like putting my
King on one of those diagonals that
makes me nervous
I see okay okay I just wanted to make
sure King a4 is not possible but I don't
think it should work or
so oh wait no so yeah the something for
black I was gonna say is you can't
actually play g5 instead of King age for
g5 would save some time and promoting
the pawn but unfortunately why can no
promote the jeep on with check yeah and
that would be devastating to be the
problem but but here though King takes
h4 if you go for c4 you have to be
careful so maybe it can just be very
fancy and go King g5
this is this King of Pop game is
actually kind of interesting maybe
instead of king d3 white should be
playing b4 and this makes the pawn a
little bit more more outside that would
probably be yeah the show is a job done
now for example you you actually have to
take so you have to recapture and then
King takes now we have an a pawn which
is just a bit faster than than the H pun
and of course there's the classics well
oh wait a second that's the problem I
feel like we might have gotten it wrong
first your long time ago but hey it's a
very interesting endgame so why wouldn't
we just try it regardless like shows not
know yeah and played Bishop d7
this could be a true this one does look
like a drug yeah but um let's go back to
the extra game we went we went so I'm
going to fire black chose not to play
Bishop e6 cuz this the same game should
be winning for white I think we messed
something up along the way but Bishop d7
doesn't allow the trade of the minor
pieces it does allow this White King to
get in and it forces this Bishop to the
d7 square and I think eventually the e8
square is nice to go back and forth the
only ways is available now why Denise to
try to find some way to put blackens up
slang I mean so I think Knight h7 and
Knight f6 is actually quite tempting yes
because but the thing is it looks like
Bishop e8 black just misses if I play
Knight h7 and you play King e6 now after
Knight f6 there's there's no good square
the bishop well I I would probably just
go to f7 yes
maybe I'm getting myself into trouble
actually I don't want to give up my e
pontius jet it's it's not as easy I
think to improve you would love to get
actually I think this position in this
position you would want to play Knight
h7 because then q6 is not possible
because Knight of fate but the question
is can you find some way to give the
move to your opponent that's well
there's some tempting moves for it for
white you can even just come further
with the King maybe can try to do some
kind of triangle over here and then come
right back to c5 I don't think even know
that the King is Seth a little bit
closer to the action I'm kind of
surprised we don't really have that many
results yet by now I think in the
previous days we used to have I mean we
have one draw the players taking their
time and it's very intense
in fact least the only game to finish so
far is this Gregorio / Oprah game
against Alexi serrana which he finished
quite early on today mm-hmm
we see Justin I think yeah Justin's hard
at work there at the board this is a
very tough position well why don't we
try and find a winning idea so let's do
that
I think Justin should pass with Bishop
ei do you see any other ideas I don't I
don't think there's much else to do
unless he can find some way to bring his
Bishop somewhere but as he's King I mean
but there's no way to bring the King
because of six so III think Bishop e8 is
should be the only move I will play King
b6
and I guess maybe King d7 is this an
idea it's candy 7 I mean I can simply
pass can be 7 me I just you have to be
very careful when you place your king
and Bishop on the same bed the same
color there are some tactical patterns
yeah maybe 94 is actually quite strong
here then I go King e6 and Knight d6
bishops in the trap now that I have my
kid now looking to see semeth and this
is a true Zito I go back not yet not yet
not yet
well night maybe 98 maybe you can maybe
oh yeah I might have a few extra tempos
maybe 97 since 95 and the c5 squares
then you have to go back any a knight c5
and now eat you this is the true six
long single abyss e6 pawn yeah that's
gonna be so this lecture looks kind of
trivial for for white then you do have
to be some careful of some lines where
you let the black pieces get out but as
long as you don't do that your kinking
in bed and there's just not enough
squares for this black Bishop to really
be able to hold and the only reason is
all the pawns are blocked in the same
their own pawns so blacks own pawns are
blocked in the same color as the Bishop
and that makes it a very absolutely
difficult piece to have you cannot
really have any kind of counter play so
white is just going oh did he play
damages did we have a move or no not yet
Justin is still thinking in this more
bad news for Justin Koch Shane has 52
minutes on the clock
he's in no rush yeah this is the type of
the type that you're just happy to play
forever and ever and ever as white yeah
you're no rush to end this game
you're having a good time your Kings
more active your Knights better you have
the past pawn this is just very pleasant
yes for sure expecting a white win here
I guess right I think so yeah
so did anything catch your eye in the
other game that's really I mean a lot of
them seemed pretty balanced most of the
time we can go back if you want to Seth
well what senses we actually take a
quick look at the prize funds well I've
been here we haven't seen them yet
that's true
a group were actually playing for a
total prize fund of $22,000 first place
takes home 6,000 of that second place
gets 4,000 and then third place 3,000
and everybody walks away with something
with even the last four players getting
$1,000 to my name just for showing up
and playing in the beaker we have 14,000
dollars total first place giving 4000
second 2500 and third place $2,000 so
these players playing for a lot here the
difference between that first place and
seventh place prizes is quite
substantial so even if the players are
having a bad tournament they have a lot
to play for monetarily at least as well
as of course you know chess players
obsessed with the reading of course
always want to want to cut their losses
as much as possible make sure they're
keeping that read rating is for sure
something that they have in mind but I
think a lot of players also they just
you know like to be creative and yeah
like good games and they definitely they
could use this tournament as a training
tournament for some other tournaments oh
and we see actually Justin has given up
the c6 pawn we're also keeping on
something there that game did follow the
way we we expect so we'll get back to
that lineage - lets see this position
now Justin giving up the c6 pawn and
actually I'm just retrieving the bishop
back to the square it came from so he's
thinking I don't care about that pawn
feel free to take it I guess he'd rather
have the square for the bishop then have
the
on there to avoid some of these songs
that we were looking at yeah
and now white is going to be able to be
further from taking this b5 phone so he
needs to bring his his night to to d4 I
mean that should not be too hard but you
always have to be careful now that you
moved in if you will were to move the
knight from g5 yes black was going to
advance with the king and start having
some contra play we do have Bishop d7
and then king c5 on the board as well so
that is our current position and what's
next for the white player here I guess
black is going after patch pass with
Bishop EA again that's what I would
expect at least probably yeah because
you definitely do not want to give the
b5 pawn I mean I cannot imagine giving
that phone as well because I mean the
only idea you would want to give that
part would be to get your Bishop to b3
but there should not be sufficient
especially because White has a knight if
it would be an opposite color bishop and
game then you'd be happy cuz you just
blocked White's majority but in this
case there's a knight so the knight can
jump around attack those pawns and
eventually lose it so it's nothing to
have to wait
I think White's being very clever here
after Bishop e8 I'm expecting King d5
actually so transfer control of this you
thought six squared now the King watches
it so the knight is free to move and I
don't think there's there's much that
black can do to stop this Knight f3 to
d4 maneuver maybe
yeah because they cannot check you know
if there's just not much not much to be
done
stuff um maybe a tough tough defense for
black for sure so I think I'm gonna call
the skin I don't think there's any way
CACCI and it does not win this position
barring some you know extreme
circumstances but let's just check it
back in with Seth you see how this game
is progressed how white chose to solve
these problems of his King and it was in
fact this h3 and King H to maneuver so
we're in this position last time and H
three nights o and black one for the
Bishop d7 so we're looking earlier at
night xh 3 but we saw didn't really
didn't amount or or Naidu to g4 right
also or 963 but yeah that there wasn't
so much so black decided to go for this
sacrifice in order to be able to get
their other looking to play just have it
a little bit closer to be able to come
create some threats against White's King
you always have to be careful because
just because you have the Queen doesn't
mean you have to win the game right the
King safety is number one it is still
possible of course of course and there
are still some very annoying pieces over
here dad you have to you know to
consider tactical ideas but I think
after King h2 wise King should be pretty
safe or is list for a few moments until
the Bishop and chases your own Erdos of
course chasing this King we saw this in
a game I think with Justin Wang much
earlier where you play to recap one when
the King was on it yeah a foul and he
played rook e1 yeah and then to the D
file and actually playing yeah I think
maybe maybe a minor thing Christopher
you maybe I think that was Christopher's
game that's the one yeah yeah white
against us maybe that was the game yeah
just chasing everyone yes Bishop d6 died
I don't think this is too much to worry
about for white and now Queen b3 check
and Quincy - oopsie so now you
for my party played oh wow brookey flora
was on the board
okay giving up the night in exchange for
the other night perhaps well the thing
is if I play g3 yeah I believe that move
actually was play both of their players
are in time trouble right now pretty low
in the clock so they have to move a
little bit faster and they were kind of
you know around move 20 and when when we
lost stop looking at this game and now
don't nine moves to play before they get
that extra half-hour added on and so we
have more moves Bishop takes that fort
she takes up four and ninety three all
on the board and somehow black I think
has ended up with more pieces than he
should have
why had a full full queen for a rook and
now if you remember the first day I
believe it did commentary for round one
victory maybe it was round two he was in
a much worse position we signed off
saying that probably he would lose that
position then this was far as game maybe
Victor this he's game two or maybe we're
still looking at it and it was an
endgame he was playing he he started the
position having a palm down and then it
was that that game where there was a
queen going to e4 I forgot exactly who
she was a calling
if it was boring anyways yeah so the
defendant really well and then he went
from having a pawn down to having upon
us so he's definitely you know that's
someone you should don't want to count
them out it is quite tough to not prefer
white here I mean why should still be
winning here and but I think it has life
is game simple sometimes he's got
something he's got something well we do
have a result in groupie our key matchup
of the day has actually ended federico
press has
she drawn his game against Alexi Sorkin
Alexi moving to three out of four with
this draw still in clear first but that
does leave the door open for Mellie
cotton for example who is doing quite
nicely in his game against Justin that
we saw leaves the door open for him to
perhaps catch the leader and go into the
or make it a tie for first place yes
indeed and I actually I was not
expecting a throw in this position was
pretty balanced a bit early let's let's
look a little bit the last couple of
moves that were happening after we
stopped looking at this game I believe I
had the game around here or so idea we
said black was going to do something
that night at 4:00 and he actually did
bring his Knight to f4 and we were
imagining some rope getting somewhere to
g5 there would have been a great idea
difficult to achieve that it's very
difficult because well when as you pass
three five maybe you have to think that
there are no maybe Forks or something
who knows but Queen g5 makes it now
having some threads so King h1 and I
guess the sacrificing h3s are going to
be enough in this position for black so
that's the reason why it's tempting but
the white knights and also the white
major pieces are very close to the king
yeah especially like I really like these
Knights control you know g2 in h2 so
unless you get really this rook to come
on sixth rank you're going to do not be
able to actually build up any kind of
attack so Queen g6 after a white is just
opening up their Queen bringing in
directly a piece to defend their king
and now the players seem like they just
made a few moves to reach the move 30
enough for a draw maybe yes sir it seems
like they're just you know neither
player can really advance
giving something up right it's tough to
find find the way of forward I mean
white can play something like these six
eventually to try to shake loose these
pawns in the center that's it seems
slightly risky in a nun game this pawn
could be weak yeah but it's also easy to
think about how to trade the pieces wait
I would love to play g5g for but yeah
you know I go crazy sometimes so you
should not take me up on that
necessarily a little terrifying it is
but even though white does not have the
bishops you shouldn't be too worried
that you know your king would be in that
much of a danger but I would probably do
that if somehow you know this b6 was
impossible because I would always think
okay maybe there's a way I could get my
King on the other side of the board yeah
you know so oh it's good to dream since
I hear Rico and Alexis now the player
wanting to really eight and go to crazy
and and start risking things of course
they're both having very reasonable
tournaments Federico was on two out of
three going into today we're select C
having the best tournament in the B
group with two and a half three advance
for further in the tournament and keep
keep their scores nice and pretty Melik
Cotchin has officially defeated Justin
wing and that game actually the Jeep on
ended up hanging I was expecting how how
did that how did that happen it looks
just like a five how did that happen so
fast all right okay so he tried
something but yeah well we take a look
at the end of this game I believe we
actually have catching in for an
interview step out of the studio and
hopefully rejoin you after this this
interview so it's great just let me know
if anyone has any kind of cool questions
to ask him yes we'll see we'll see all
right so as we are waiting for Malik to
come into the room for an interview let
us take a look at some other games we
had not looked at this game between
harutunian and Cordova this seems like a
great position for black well the white
has this further away past porn I think
black has some chances but we have Malik
here with us today so hi Malik nice game
yeah that's right that's right tell us
how do you feel about being here and
about the tournament so far so far so
good
I'm actually a bit surprised I'm playing
so well I thought it'd be like much
worse after this like crucial is you
know five days of Ranchester but I'm not
I'm so far I'm making restitution so
yeah it looks like we're having a great
tournament so oh yeah maybe this will
help you to come back from retirement
and play some more chess and do a little
bit less coaching coaching is my main
job obviously but I mean playing it's
also important you know that yeah
because you know we have to play
sometimes just to keep our save himself
in the in the shape so yeah I thought
that mean comfy too tired but then I
figure no I miss chess so I had to I had
to play all right take us to to maybe
some of the key points of the game we
yeah well you prefer this one obviously
I when I study his games I noticed the
kid is very practical and stuff at that
and being a little bit aging player so
you understand I have to like a make
some adjustment yeah this is great stuff
when I used to play this line like for
maybe like 20 45 years ago so mm-hmm
so I thought the system that prepared I
actually mostly focus on a direct
approach from blacks perspective playing
c5 Sabina so this is supposed over here
yeah this is supposed to be them they
you know concrete approach from blacks
perspective but I thought I found
something interesting from my engine
so I was thinking to consider to play
here at the main line that D - all that
d5 which is like international exit 95
yeah they're interesting yeah it's not a
big deal to be honest but you know as a
surprising weapon to play yeah and
especially if he wasn't prepared anyway
back to the game so we should be seven
also quite normal but we should be seven
allows me to play Bishop f4 mm-hmm so
now my bishop gets main diagonal
basically what's going on here if you
challenge me let's say we should be six
that pawn structure always benefi why'd
you just shut down on the six and play
Castle queenside and then just yeah this
is like a tiny bit of a while but I like
those positions you know I'll be like
like my good friend
- Jessica I keep saying massaging here
so yeah I mean I was sort of expecting
this but the kid - Brandon says okay so
quit shop first yeah guess so Queen the
neck is seven which is fine H 496 this
is all normal
do you 3 h5 know about f3 this is the
first move which I thought a little bit
inaccuracy like we should before mm-hmm
so basically my c3 Knight doesn't do
much anyway yeah so you have to improve
it anyways absolutely so bye-bye charge
of mine I was helping you
exactly nobody what do you think would
have been better ah c5 do black need to
get back to Bishop d6 mm-hmm so it may
be prepared like move this bishop
actually right the way straight uh-huh
so just yeah but then you'd probably
still take an okay but then you're not
just six actually justifies himself
because you can chose f4 it was breaking
c7 I still believe this is about eco
maybe telling better for me but again
not a big deal mm-hmm okay so this is
somehow helping you today understand you
know I think the black simply wanted to
have more like a more ambitious and okay
but after this after initiated the first
rate is very important for me to trade
at night mm-hmm
because in such poor structure as we all
understand basically what has extra pawn
almost yes the g4 what in such cases is
just simplifying
yeah and eventually you're going to play
something like this but you are going to
prepare yeah this is still okay still
hold about obviously eight three yeah
the point of a tree move was in many
lines of my calculation a two powers
sort of troublemaker
mmm-hmm so I thought I put my poem a
tree and he said like no known structure
right Sabina yeah you when you play
against three or four what you do you
put your fault like yeah and you did
that in the game advice right it's not
amazing because he stayed with the light
square bishop so that was right yeah I
mean it's a classical game so Fisher a
lot of games kind of fun structure so a
three yeah first challenge c5 finally he
moved forward that's key to but this is
the thing I believe Bishop e6 fine yeah
rook Devon taketake okay
and then I think this is too much yeah
before doesn't seem I've seen other
people maybe keeping their pawns like
this absolutely you have the correct
Sabina yeah because you coach think you
know the stuff so typically in such pawn
structure
you always keep your beep one won't be
six unless if you see concrete like
forward moving yeah because usually
since your main bishop here it's a six
bishop so what you want to do you want
to keep your plus you have a bishop so
it makes a lot of sense right points on
black to annoy your bishop yeah yeah b5
seems definitely no you're absolutely
correct yeah BC I was expecting so after
this now he must play seasick yeah I
said now there's another problem because
now I got the d6 square this is what
usually happens when you push the pause
that's why I tell you you know they
don't go back so make sure listen this
point here it took me forever because I
could understand how do I make a problem
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone we are back we had some
small technical difficulty but we're
back here with grandmaster melle kichan
who has just won his game against the
young talented justin wang and we were
going over the game he was just
explaining to us how awesome it is to
have majority on the Kings side make
sure your opponent's majority stays
block there bring your king on the side
where you have your majority yeah that's
right yeah and and I feed this to the
basically from here I didn't you I have
a chance to win but may mistake still
Sabine I thought this is still horrible
like a 5 what he did initiate was right
we should be Sigma chef g7 all those
moves are okay Bishop is f4 Bishop e6
yeah what I think what black has to do
here it just stayed you know yeah just
wait just wait because the main mistake
you can point out immediately when he
played Bishop GFF way to move 31 trading
that bishop yeah we we actually have not
seen this point we're looking at your
game a little bit later but that's
certainly stay here like you know that's
the you know I don't know like maybe a
four maybe King b7 yesterday maybe he
was thinking if you trace the dark
square Bishop he gets the chance to play
d4 but probably you move the knight i
mean ii mean you're like a two major
mistake he went bishop f8 and suddenly
fees become very very sad you just have
to be super fade i have no access to ya
square i didn't find out the size a
mistake when he played absolutely
unexpectedly like a king b6 it was a
game over he needs to stay on c7 at
least to cover up the missing the bishop
and cover this six square
no problem is this is still losing by
the way i was thinking to play suffolk
like either a for either way at some
point john is a beef iphone and then
calling before and then i p1 or like a
classic not be one that the to c3 and
then just a slowly for AA you would go
to f3 even maybe
it's step by step here but he did some
patience yeah and after that we really
just don't we really enjoyed the the end
the endgame yeah this is like Riddick
like yeah it's like an pacing like this
is a simple lesson because yoga you
control duct squares and he probably
also means like if I've f EF V him is
the king before idea I was thinking here
the main move is actually king b6 and
then history losing because I played now
yeah 95 yeah
95 so actually not not Kim b6 I thought
okay the only move to stop a king king
c5 but not before and that's why I chose
this version to make sure there's no
look f2 then your king is entering all
right at that point and then just try to
not to be you had more whites for the
moment right lucky three whites then
you're gonna well yesterday yesterday
Sean like push me like to the brink I
mean I thought I'm going I was analyzing
the game yesterday's video just a game
by the way super interesting game yeah
super complex I thought white was
winning clearly but I guess I was wrong
so no that's right oh yeah sure and he
also thought he was clearly winning but
no there's always some chances there
it's always been complicated yeah wait
wait that's right it's a long tournament
yeah thanks for joining us today we're
absolutely should good luck in there
anything anything care was black
yeah yeah we'll see you again soon all
right hopefully hopefully you know I
love you so be sure I'm gonna come back
here again
thank you alright so that was
Grandmaster Malik catchy on the captain
of US Olympic team and he's showing some
great chess here in San Luis let's see
we're going to have Caleb back with us
in just a few moments and meanwhile I'm
trying to see going back to our key
matchup of the
the game between Sam seven and Hannah's
caboose Ian this is the game that we
thought it will be the most interesting
of today's round indie a group and um
Oh a lot of things have changed Caleb
yes what do you think
well once again my greatest insight into
the decision is the number of pawns that
is true White has morph
I believe if my count is correct it is
five to four yes but you know seriously
looking here though I think black has
good holding chances and that's due to
this h4 pawns for for black yeah I feel
like this is bring brings the put the
damper on things
the question is is this a drawn up well
actually looking at the position I
thought it was white to move and I know
I'm sorry now that I know that it's
black it is liked and I think it's
definitely a draw yeah g3 I don't think
you or maybe not maybe Queen d2 that's
what I was thinking but let us not
forget about some activity now
promenades engage five if the King
straight the Queen straits too far then
this Queenie Wanda Jesus yeah it's
simply going to to kill the game I feel
like we're going to see a there was a
move there was a move what did I miss
the 21 was actually played in this
position so I feel like we're going to
have a draw in this game unless you're
missing some kind of the only tractor
white is this Queen g1 right and and
then they're going from g1 just simply
isn't going to be useful to get it done
it's very tricky when you are playing
the Queen and game because you just have
to always be careful for checks you need
to make sure I'm not going to to allow
the opponent to give you a perpetual
check you need to make sure your pawns
are safe yeah not to lose too many of
them so I'm not sure it looks like Sam
is contemplating whether he should take
the draw or not I think he probably will
take the draw here having trouble
believing that Queen g1 with that
the work he's clearly not very happy
about it maybe there are some chances
you had me missed earlier in the game we
kind of catch back up from from where we
let's see where we were yeah we were
around move 30 I remember I don't
remember exactly which one somewhere
around here where some trains had
happened and then we were trying to
figure out what were the plans so let's
see let's let's what you learn what do
they do
night of sex okay I mean so that night
definitely had to be improved yes and
now the night is brought to G for you
shop G 1 this is very typical you do not
want to give up that dark square Bishop
of white of course not the night went to
h4 and now Knight to g3 what I always
thought is very happy in King Indian
position Kings Indian positions or
Benoni to give up this light square
bishop because you know oftentimes it's
blocked but its own pawns so I think I
should be happy with this train but if
with black you want to try to attack you
probably should get rid of that bishop
so rook took Queen f7 looking at this d5
pawn and maybe having some ideas to
bring the Queen towards the attack and
we did mention earlier white possibly
sacrificing the d5 pawn for yeah but now
the bishop then it just doesn't make
sense yeah it doesn't make as much sense
so now h3 is being played you have to go
back to h6 in a way white force black to
get the knight or not such a great
position and now Queen to d1 protecting
that d5 pawn so what does get this file
now so white immediately changes that
make sure that oh wow Queens you honest
played and we actually have a queen
trade from black what let's good job
let's get out it is that was traded 9 to
c4 all right so Sam did give up that
pawn temporary and now we have Bishop
takes d4 because if you
take with with the queen for example
that would be awesome I think for not
would that be awesome why I think why
it's just in time to catch this deep on
and has in fact defeated his opponent
using that extra Queen to take down
Viktor Erdos and Viktor just just
resigning I think the big problem for
black in that game was this King was a
bit weak yes stick with this game for a
moment next is this game and see what
what happens so Knight to e5 oh this is
beautiful pin and the other pin yeah
double pins
you cannot take my knight and we're
putting a lot of pressure on f7
threatening to take the nine f7 and then
the pawn on d6 or yeah d6 started to
five how we achieved our current
position yeah and now I did not rush to
take that pawn in the 61st improve the
position of his king by playing King to
h2 and now h4 and this is a very good
idea that black has come up with getting
this Queen you know this pawn to h4 and
having the idea that in some endgame the
Queen could give a perpetual check which
we have seen could've happened
absolutely and now it's time there are
no more improvement moves for white and
disposition if everyone wanting to try
something you have to trade the night
and then capture the pawn in d6 and here
of course you cannot trade the Queen's
because this pawn is going to be very
annoying okay I believe yeah double
checked it but I believe so I mean is it
yeah so yeah we're just in time to get
into the e4 square and then from there
we're just gonna I was gonna place me at
king of three and then d3 and I'll
distract your king and take your oh this
should be yeah this should be okay
alright so same one for 25 in this
position looking at that a five point as
well now King h6 trying to escape with
the king from some Czech patterns and
now
bringing the Kings so black didn't want
to stay and wait because white can just
have this you know very good idea of
bringing the king a little bit closer
and then we can consider trading the
Queens because our queen king in f2
would be much closer than that king h6
so black sacrifices the deep one to get
this padding that we just saw one in
Queen g3 they repeated the position
didn't didn't they repeat it three times
am I having some I think just twice this
is one
oh you can keep watching th one alright
and then one happened Queen g1 from
White Queen takes Gaea one and yeah this
was the big surprises Queen takes g1
from Obama's caboose Ian and I suppose
he's calculated this endgame and he
thinks that it's simply nothing for for
white I need a moment I don't trust it
oh I do whites very very well might be
might be winning this game I just don't
understand
you could just play Queen d2 why why
would you go for an endgame like why
would you spend the time calculated this
when you could just go for Queen d2 what
are we missing here is there any move
that white can play this is a very
strange decision it should be but yeah
we are running a bit short on time so
maybe we should take a quick run around
all the boards see what we are
predicting for the end that's rose I
think this is Geoffrey Jean versus nerd
its key game and has turned out to be
quite interesting now there was another
game that I wanted to look at we didn't
have that much time to look at that game
I think Geoffrey for the moment is up
upon and after let's see 7 things I'm
looking slightly awkward for for the
black pieces
I think Jeffrey might win this game
actually well I mean the good thing
that's happening in this position is the
fact that we have the rooks still on the
board that's something really good
because we just audition yeah if we were
if there were just the bishops this
problem would be a draw and they might
just shake hands on it but here with the
rooks on the board you have to be very
careful not to lose material but but I
mean we have you have to be concrete of
course I mean yes g-seven is a weakness
that that could be attacked
I think Roca 4 was actually just played
a show for qg8 quite quickly and
positions where the black King might
actually run into some danger if he's
not super careful but I think blacks
idea might something you could do 7 yes
sir and hold you know just just don't
push anything I'm not sure if that was
played or not yeah that was just played
it's not so easy to prove some ideas
from light you can start pushing these
phones on the on the Kings side start
making some more threats but maybe
you're holding chance or something maybe
g6 yeah you have to see but we also have
this Barco being game against you're not
juma by of this one is looking to be
drawn perhaps it's a double Brook
endgame but black strokes a bit more
active but white does have a very nice
deep on that black is going to have to
Corral eventually mm-hmm
so expecting a draw here and then over
in the probably yeah prevent wrong if
anybody has chances I would say it's
it's white because of this gospel yeah
but you also have to be very careful of
the g3 pawns
anyway we might see a draw there I think
in the B group Sergei Arenberg actually
has a
attack against Christopher you with this
riff d8 move it and now I'm expecting
Bishop e5 maybe hmm
and this work might come to h8 and it's
been a variation on the board that I
think might be white Bishop e5 should be
five and then what what does black do if
you play Bishop c3 ever khh so simply
winning for circuit Arenberg perhaps
sure what there's much else to be done
so expecting a win no way so they'll be
nice for him given that he started with
three losses in this journey
yes getting on the board finally and
with a winner nonetheless yeah and we
also have this game between route Union
and yeah there was a game that I I had
started looking at when Melek was when
you're changing yes getting him into the
studio and I saw that Malia Cordova had
an extra pawn and and and I thought he
had some chances to try to push here for
a win in this position you do have this
passed pawn already far away here in h4
but that should not be enough so the
good news for black is 3 V 1 is a very
very very favorable structure on the
side I always push those pawns quite
easily you can very easily make one to
pass pawns and this H pawn well it is
pretty far advanced I don't think it's
gonna be enough to counteract these very
powerful pawns on on the Queen side yeah
it's not not to mention it as well 46
minutes versus 2 minutes really that
that's what's going to be that's going
to be tough so that was going to change
a little bit our standings because I
believe her attorney and he has two
points so yeah he was on two out of
three one of them you today and then I
mean there was like one second place and
yeah Emilio is on one point
yes joining joining it if that were to
happen if you were to win this game and
I can predict a win in this position
I would say you know if we're trying to
make a prediction for the game the last
game we have in progress is you've been
keeping an eye on it yeah every time
every time some changes were happening
it Sergey Azeroth squares off against
Alshon Marathi Abadi and Al Shean is
holding in this position I think you
know if anybody's to be preferred you
would rather be white here with the
powerful and active rook and the active
Knights mm-hmm but I think this this one
should be well in hand for El Shawn
tonight c-4 was just laid so here he's
trying to go for the e5 pawn and but we
also are looking at this e for pawn so
now I can see option is to Pisa and in
his sense is focusing okay he's
confident he goes from 1964 or and we
see some pawns getting liquidated yeah
so 964 and now I'm assuming we're going
to see a capture in E 547 one of those
but like even if you and I'm losing both
of those pawns FQ is hanging as well
yeah good news for 4l Shawn here is that
as the defender the more pawns that get
traded off the board the closer to the
draw
yeah and and let's just you know remind
everyone that if somehow we get the
chance to take all of whites pawns we
can always trade the rooks sacrifice
both our pieces and just make a dryline
yes King you just need to make sure you
get rid of your own pawns to just in
case those pawns are not advanced enough
they're still mating chances if there's
still some points on the board but
somebody hankins well with those
predictions in mind why don't we take a
look at our standings but that internet
we have your gory Oberon we're drawing
his game today bring him his score to
two and a half out of four soul first
for the moment but we're not expecting
that to last for long
Geoffrey Shawn also on two points is
pressing a little bit against a new nerd
it's key Daniel might be able to hold
that that draw there which would bring a
wolf Geoffrey and Daniel to two and a
half from Geoffrey wins he would be sole
first we also have Rinat Juma buy of
with two points
he is playing vara Cobian in a double
rook endgame
expecting that game to maybe end in a
draw but if anybody's to be preferred we
think it's it's white and then we have
Sam studyin who is in a King and pawn
endgame which looks to be drawn but
still slightly tricky so Sam trying to
trick
Havana's caboose Ian in that game and
also bring his score to three points
bonus caboose Ian of course is defending
against Sam seven Viktor Erdos lost his
game today to Seth you Alexei Sirona
with the draw against Gregorio proned
and as we said var is playing Granada by
off in that double rook endgame
interesting so we only had two you know
two games finishing the a group which is
surprising by now I think yes I've been
playing for four hours and a lot of
games are still yet to be decided
so it's interesting let's check out the
B rope yeah I think yeah absolutely
Alexei Sorokin sure his game today
bringing him to three points out of four
and Melek Cotchin has caught Alexis
Oregon winning today against Justin Wang
in a very instructive and very beautiful
actually end game that he had prepared
with three out of four seasons joint
first place Frederico Perez poncy drew
his game against Alexi Sorkin still
staying just 1/2 point out of that
leadership position
tigran root Union is of course defending
in his game and we're expecting him to
not be able to hold actually against
Emilio Cordova yeah that's this going to
be a very tough ending which are rather
unfortunate for him
Sergei azeroth is still playing el Shawn
Moratti a buddy
but we're expecting that game to wrap up
in a draw bringing him to two and a half
on part with Federico Justin wing
unfortunately lost to Melek Emilio
Cordova is pressing very very hard
against a route Union we're expecting a
win from him bringing him to a 50% score
once again Christopher you is struggling
against Sergei Ehrenberg and else Sean
of course holding his position against
Sergei azeroth and Sergei we're
expecting to defeat Chris for you and I
believe he just officially
has in fact won that game otherwise some
very interesting results today
on both sides for sure it was great
watching some of the games today
although we haven't had decisive results
not too many yet but and a lot of games
are still playing I wish we could do
this a little bit longer but these are
our times for today
yeah I'm looking forward to tomorrow so
yeah and if you're watching home of
course you can still catch these games
live for yourself at us chess champs
calm you see just annoying they're
collecting his belongings getting out of
out of the tournament Hall be sure to
follow along on us chess champs calm for
yourself the games to watch her
definitely that Geoffrey Jean game in
the a group as well as that Sam seventh
game if either of those players manages
to win they go into Seoul first and the
a group also in the B group keep an eye
on vara Cobian yeah in the a group keep
an eye on vara Kobe ins game as well he
might find some chances again Serena
it's possible he's really he really
wants to come back after two tough to
tough losses the first two rounds then
he won yesterday is certainly in
fighting spirit getting some getting the
points rolling in yeah well that's about
it for our coverage here today thank you
guys so much for joining us as always we
will be live tomorrow at 3:30 p.m.
once again Bensimon will be filling in
for me one last time so be sure to catch
that yeah I'm sure it'll be a fantastic
show I just wanted also to thank
everyone for yes working on this
production with us of course Ben and
Isaac
as well as Tony and they're working hard
as well yep and the players for giving
us such great games and of course the
the arbiters yes you know making sure
the tournament around smoothly a lot of
people behind the scenes making sure
everything gets done here of course so
thanks for that and we hope you continue
watching the tournament and we'll see
you tomorrow
be sure to join us tomorrow at 3:30 p.m.
for more coverage of the 2019 winter
chess classic
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st.
Louis chess club
you